nathalie première fois didier premier
souvenir
je devais avoir un an et demi ou deux
ans et mon papa m'emmenait dans un
espèce de casting je crois et je vais
être sur scène et bouger avec la chanson
où la chanteuse avait amoureuse nom ou
la menteuse elle est amoureuse par un et
je me sentais très mal et je me suis
mise à pleurer et mon père m'a pris dans
ses bras et on a posé sur une table où
il y avait plein de chaussures et le mec
qui faisait le casting nous a demandé
d'en choisir une
et mon père a pris juste celle que je
voulais pas et j'espérais vraiment qu'il
avait pas prendre c'est donc vers les
vannes d'un truc énorme notre jeu c est
pour en parler pendant des heures c'est
vraiment un truc il a marqué que la
refuser le casting très très jeune à 8
sur les musiques de dorothée en plus
traumatiques premier choc
le père noël qui existent par intérim
j'ai pleuré ça m'a traumatisée que l'âge
qu'un second cible en six ans un premier
péché
l'envy de luxure peut-être à 4 ans avec
mathieu la [ __ ]
4-4 classement 1ère bac alors celle dont
je me souvienne mais c'était sans doute
pas la première je devais avoir 8 ans et
et je courais pour pas que ma maman me
foute une basse et helm a loupé elle m'a
tapé dans le ventre et ça m'a fait très
mal
il ya là père de l'enfant
voyez coup de foudre matière assez
mature maintenant après premier baiser
sur la bouche dans une fête en belgique
jerry 12 ans avec la langue
alors en fait ça ces bases et
bizarrement voulait la vraie histoire
parce qu'il ya eu jerry sans la langue
est en fait j'ai traversé la rue et y en
avait un autre qui était julien élusate
avec la halle en cas d'accord le même
jour sur la vigne avec l'habitat leur
accord les trois premières fois 14 ans
avec alex un manteau rose on sait jaune
ben ça c'est tout est de la faute de
mathieu sans doute quant à lui lancé un
appel pour alex bon sens ou pas ouais
y'a que mathieu au fait que le droit de
revenir quoi mais non mais c'est
l'espèce si ça se trouve
inconsciemment je ne fait que chercher
l'image de mathieu que je ne retrouverai
jamais il suffirait que je le revois
pour que première fois à troyes jamais
pas lent trop de problèmes à 2 pourra
être à 3 pour l'instant première fois
quatre mois à peine que je vous demande
mon premier chagrin d'amour
vrai chagrin d'amour c'était ya pas très
longtemps il ya enfin ça a duré trois
ans aussi longtemps que l'histoire et
c'était avec mon petit ami américain
c'était comment tu faisais quoi
actares première tentative de suicide
mathieu 15 ans 15 ans ouais pourquoi gcp
dernière chose que vous feriez si vous
deviez mourir là maintenant tout de
suite
overdose de drogues dures